네 그래서 이태원역 상권은 한국 전쟁
이후에 미군들이 이쪽에 거주하기
시작하면서 상권이 좀 발달되기
시작했고 우리나라에서 유일하게 좀
외국 문화를 느낄 수 있는 그런 좀
특색 있는 어 그런 상권으로 보시면
될 거 같아요 이쪽 앞쪽에는 그
해방촌이 있는데 우리나라에서 외국인이
가장 많이 거주하는 어 그런 동네라고
좀 보시면 될 거 같아요 그래서 그런
외국인에 맞춰서 이렇게 좀 특색 있고
좀 다양한 이런 문화들이 좀 접목돼
있는 그런 상권이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그리고 본격 적으로 좀
상권이 활성화하게 되게 된 건
1988년도에 올림픽 이후에 세계
각지에 있는 관광객들이 많이 오면서
상권이 더 발달되기 시작했고
본격적으로 좀 상권이 가장 활발하게
된 거는 2010년도에 어 여기 고급
레스토랑들이 많이 들어오면서 그때가
아마 이태원 상권에 가장 좀 활성화된
식이지 않나 이렇게 생각을 합니다
젠트리피케이션이 일어나면서 여기
기존에 있던 임차인들이 외곽으로
쫓겨나기 시작했어요 그러면서 발생된게
경리단길 상권입니다 여기 기존
임차인들이 경리단길 상권이 가면서
상권이 활발해 되기 시작했고 상권이
계속 이어져 오다가 거기가 아무래도
언덕길이 되게 심하고 접근하기가 좀
쉽지 않다 보니까 경리단 길이 좀
많이 침체되어 있는 어 그런 시기라고
보시면 될 거 같고 지자체에도 거기
상권을 좀 살리기 위해서 많은
노력들을 하고 있는 것으로 알려져
있습니다 그리고 이태원동 상권이 명동
상권이라 조금 다르게 여기는 국내
사람들이 꽤 와요 명동 같은 경우에는
외국인 의존도가 되게 높은데 태 상권
같은 경우에는 국내 사람들도 어 많이
이용하는 그런 상권이라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다 아무래도 여기가 외국인
수요가 많다 보니까 코로나 때 좀
직격탄을 많이 받았어요 그때 공실률이
거의 한 3 40% 정도로 건물이
진짜 많이 비어 있었습니다 그러다가
이제 코로나가 조금 회복되면서
공실률이 조금 회복되기 시작했고 근데
제가 지금 오늘도 현장이 와서 봤지만
공실률이 완전히 좀 회복되진 않은 거
같아요 그래서 좀 비어 있는 건물들도
많고 해밀턴 바로 이면이 상권이 가장
좋긴 하는데 거기도 비어 있 건물들이
꽤 있더라고요 해밀턴에서 경리 단기를
올라가는 길 쪽에는 공실이 좀 많이
눈에 띄었습니다 좀 전체적으로 좀
공실률이 좀 높은 거 같아요 불가
진짜 제가 2010년도 하더라도 여기
지금 커피스미스 자리 외국인
관광객들이나 거기 거주하신 분들이
굉장히 많았거든요 근데 지금 그
건물이 비어 있는 거 보면서 어 좀
상권이 좀 그때보다는 많이 죽었구나
이렇게 좀 생각이 듭니다
[음악]
저희가 지금 이태원역에서 경리단길
가는 쪽 초입에 와 있는데 지금 뒤에
보이는 저건물이 오해 매각된
사례입니다 그래서 매각된 금액은
26억 4천에 매각이 됐고 대지
면적은 그렇게 크지가 않아요 한
20평대 정도 되고 옆 면적도 한
20평대 근데 이제 50년도 지어서
건폐율을 거의 100% 가까이
받았어요 일전에 매입한 금액을 보니까
2020년도에 20억 9천에 매입을
했더라고요 그래서 매각하신 분은 사실
세금이나 이런 거 때문에는 그렇게
남지는 못했습니다 일단은 지금 임차가
좀 맞춰져 있긴 하는데 여기 임대
상황이 그렇게 좋지 않아요 만약에이
임차인이 나가게 된다면이 정도 면적에
어 어느 정도 임대료를 낼 수 있는
임차인을 찾아야 되는데 쌍 면적이
그렇게 크지 않지만 어 금액을 좀
높은 수준으로 저는 매입했다고
개인적으로 생각하기 때문에 나중에
얼마에 과연 매각할지 여러분들 한번
좀 지켜보시면 좋을 것 같아요
그래서 제가 또 매각 사를 설명드릴
건데 저기 뒤에 보이는 저 건물입니다
이태원역에서 위치가 굉장히 좀 좋은
어 그런 건물인데 원래는 한 3 4층
정도 되는 되게 낡은 건물이었어요
2019년도에 다 매입을 했습니다 총
매입가는 440억 원 정도에 매입을
했고 대지는 한 260평 정도 돼요
상업지 보니까 건물을 좀 높게 올릴
수 있습니다 보통은 일반 상업지가
800% 지데 한 400%대 정도
받았어요데 여기 건축 제한들이 좀
있다 보니까 지금이 건물 상태가
어떻게 보면 최대한 용적률을 받은
것이라고 좀 보시면 될 거 같아요
지금 위치가 굉장히 좋다 보니까
무신사 스튜디오가 들어와 있거든요
음식점도 들어와 있고 그리고 1층이
지금 공실이 이긴 하지만 가려서 받는
거 같아요 임대 컨디션은 굉장히 좀
좋은 건물이라고 보시면 되고 그리고
지금 우측에 보시면은 저기 전광판이
있어요 정말 엄청난 수익이 나올 것
같습니다 뭐 원래 얘는 아예 전광판이
없었는데 되게 좀 가시성이 아무래도
좋은 건물이다 보니까 그래서 좀
수익성이 나와서 전광판을 달지
않았을까 이렇게 예상을 합니다 지금이
건물은 지하 3층에 지상 8층 정도
규모의 빌딩입니다 그리고 토지 메이
가만 440억이 넘기 때문에 사이즈가
좀 크긴 합니다 어 임대 수요는 좀
괜찮긴 하지만 사이즈 가 좀 이태원
치고 좀 크긴 해 가지고 나중에 이제
매각에 대한 그런 황금성에 대한 좀
문제가 있을 것 같은데 어찌됐든 지금
이쪽 근처에는 좀 좋은 위치에 대게
개발을 잘한 사례라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다네 그래서 이태 운동 전망을
하자면 명돈 편과 좀 대비를 할 수
있는데 명동 같은 경우에는 국내
사람들이 그렇게 많이 가지 않습니다
근데 이태원동 같은 경우에는 한국에서
유일하게 외국 문화를 밀접하게 접할
수 있는 데가 이태 운동이든 그니까
이제 2 30대 분들이 이태 운동을
많이 찾습니다 그리고 외국인
관광객들이 지금 한국을 많이 찾고
있거든요이 한류 열풍이 계속 이어지는
하는 외국인들이 한국에 더 많이 올
것으로 예상이 됩니다 좀 더 좋아질
것이라고 저는 예상을 하는데 근데
여기서 아셔야 될게 제가 말하는
이태원동 상권은 그 해밀턴 호텔
인근입니다 거기 바로 이면에 이태
원동을 보시면은 거기 언덕길이 되게
많아요 경리단길 같은 경우에는
언덕길이 매우 심합니다 예전 같은
경우에는 경리단 길이 상권이 되게
좋긴 했 지만 잘 돌아오지 못하고
있어요 그 이유 중에 가장 큰게
언덕길이 매우 심합니다 그래서 이거는
어떻게 보면 상권의 기본이에요
초입에서 하야트 아지 걸어가려면 진짜
너무 힘들어요 근데 해밀턴은 바로 역
나오자마자 뒤에 있잖아요 그래서
접근성이 매우 좋습니다 태 운동뿐만
아니라 이렇게 생겨나는 그런 상권들
있잖아요 접근하기가 어렵거나 뭐
언덕길이 되게 심하거나 아니면 되게
좁은 도로에 있거나 이런 상권 같은
경우에는 제 개인적인 생각엔 되게
오래 가지 못하는 거 같습니다 정리해
보자면 해밀턴 호텔 인근 근의 상권은
앞으로 좀 더 좋아질 것으로 예상이
됩니다 언덕길이 있거나 애매한 위치의
상권은 오래 유지되거나 좀 더 좋아질
거라는 생각은 개인적으로 하지 않고
있습니다 그래서 이태 운동은 뭔가
대한민국의 뭔가 좀 특색 있는 좀
강력하고 뭔가 차별화된 그런
상권이라고 생각하기 때문에 저 전망은
되게 좀 좋게 보긴 하지만 계속
말씀드렸던 그 상권의 기본 조건
언덕길이 없고 내리막길이 없고 도로가
좁지 말아야 되고 진출입이 좋아야
되고 기본적인 조건에 만 는 곳에
투자를 하셔야지 좀 이런 실패확률을
좀 줄일 수가 있습니다 그리고
이태원동에 있는 건물들이 대부분 좀
이런 노화된 건물들이 되게 많아요
이태원역 앞에 있는 건물 같은
경우에는 뭐 상업 지역이긴 한데 원래
상업지가 용적률이 800% 아아 일반
상업지가 뭐 고도 제한이라는 뭐 지구
단위 계획이라는 뭐 이런 것 때문에
건물을 80000% 못 받는 경우도
되게 많거든요 그리고 이제 건물이
워낙 노화된 것들이 많고 이렇게
따닥따닥 붙어 있는 경우가 많기
때문에 만약에 거기서 개발 행위를
한다라고 하면 는 꼭 건축사랑 미리
상의를 통해서 어 건축 행위가 되는지
그리고 했을 때 어느 정도 규모의
사이즈의 건물이 나오는지 미리
건축사랑 좀 협의해 가지고 이런 건축
행위를 진행하셨으면 좋겠습니다 그래서
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다
빌딩은
[음악]
빌사남 di